we met erica i'd like you to meet her
too roll the tape
hi drew my name is erica i am a mom
of two and i work at home full-time i am
on video calls
all day and there's one thing that i
constantly notice
and it's my eye area my brows are really
thin
from years and years of plucking and i
can't find a way to fill them without
looking
fake my eyelashes are really light
and no matter what type of mascara or
lash product that i use it seems like
they always just kind of blend
in my hair is very fine and
straight and i use all sorts of products
to try to get a little bit of wave
or a little bit of a body in there but
nothing ever seems to hold
help drew help i am here
for you erica hello
hi hi thank you i i definitely need some
help
first of all you're already beautiful
now let's
oh thank you all right thank you thank
you it's true
um i've been excited to do this with you
and i've really thought
a lot about the products that we sent i
personally curated them
so i sent you some products that will
give you hopefully
a little bit of a performance driven low
maintenance routine
with a high maintenance look all right
do you have your box
i do i have my box so cute okay let's
open her up
first what i would like you to do is
pull out this this is kiehl's
ultra face cream the reason i
love this is because i want a
moisturizer
a moisturizer that's going to give me a
fresh dewy
supple look but not move my makeup
around
that makes me mad this is fantastic
it's also really good for your skin all
right so start with that
then i want you to find your favorite
foundation or concealer
then what i went ahead and did is i
picked out these two
pixie colors i love pixie it's just a
fantastic brand and i even worked
with um one of their formulators uh that
they worked on that brand with our brand
flower beauty
and they're just they're really great
and very affordable
this is called the endless
shade stick but really what i like about
it
is it's gonna give you kind of a smoky
look
but i gave you these really subtle
colors and by the way
i promise you i like this because you
can even see i do the same effect
on my own eyes robin fredericks who does
my makeup it's just
so easy to put on you smudge out the
edges with your finger
they're really pretty tones and very
foolproof
to apply then i'm going to want you
to take this benefit by the way since
this is the cutest little packaging
it's the benefit roller lash and i love
benefit i've been a big fan for as long
as i can remember
what i love about this is it's tiny low
maintenance and
it has a rubber head
um bristles or rubber make a big
difference in application
a good tip is to go across
from the baseline i want you to get as
low as you possibly can
to that eyeball without hurting yourself
but you want to go low
and lift and then if you want to turn it
around
and go in that way to continue to
discover lashes
do it ask a dumb question yes please
do you put the mascara on top of the
lashes or just
underneath definitely you can if you
like to
but what you really want to do is you
want to go
literally to almost the eyeball without
hurting yourself
the whole point is you want to go and
lift
lift lift lift lift
high maintenance without putting on
lashes
i love it erica your eyes look so
beautiful
thank you i love them all right now
for your eyebrows this is
a flower beauty product which is um the
company
that i have it's called fiber fix
the reason i love this is because
there's a little spoolie at the end
it is hard to work with markers
even pencils can be difficult
this i love because it's a spoolie
so i want you to go in the eyebrows that
you already have
don't go outside the lines just work
with what you've got
the really important key i think
to the color tone of brows
is to make sure that there's enough
green or
warm tones in them because natural hair
has green or warm tones i love them they
don't look too
like over shaped either they just look
natural i love that i love the color you
look
so gorgeous okay now quickly speaking of
flower beauty throw this product on i'm
obsessed with this
it's called color shift it's a universal
neutral color
and it's just it comes in a really fun
squeezy tube and i love
the interaction with this now i'm
already wearing a lipstick
but it is um
do you know what i love about this it's
a mood ring basically
of um lip glosses it's going to respond
to
your natural pigment and work
accordingly so it's going to look a
little different on every person but
what you want it to do
is just bring out your own natural oh my
gosh
by the way do you see how see-through
that is
that is your own natural pigment that
it's picking up
that's why it's a mood ring i got some
pigment okay erica you look
stunning and at the end of the day
when it's all said and done i can't tell
you how
important it is to wash it off so that
you can start the next day with a clean
fresh palette so i got you
the milk makeup matcha stick it's a
fantastic cleanser
milk is one of my favorite beauty brands
anna roberts rassi who created it
um with her team as a friend of the show
so you want to go and a stick is just a
fun way to interact in a cleansing it's
not
boring and listen those things
psychologically count
so you're going to take it all off and
guess what
throw a little moisturizer back on
you're gonna come full circle with this
erica
i cannot tell you how beautiful you look
and it looks like effort was put in
which i think is a really nice
compliment to people when they see you
on
zoom that you care enough to put in that
effort
but you don't look like you're trying
too hard at the same time you're in that
perfect pretty little middle
this is perfect this is like a little
bit of a makeup kit i can keep in my
desk drawer
exactly and bring it out when i need it
and i feel like it's so easy
and it just made such a difference and i
feel better about how i'm showing up so
and as a little uh last minute bonus
erica i know you always want to do a
little something for your hair
now doing one's own hair can be really
intimidating i have a really great
flower hair tool for you and you can go
and it gives you a little bit of bend
because let's face it a little bit of
bend around the face
makes a big difference i do it it works
thank you so much
i love my uh beauty box and thank you so
much for sharing your tips with me
i can't tell you how fun this was for me
and seeing the results
meow thank you erica